what did you do so you you came off
social media i i got rid of my phone
completely still i have a phone you
should try it
man it's decent way to sober up on that
huh seriously
no it's good i got i got uh bought an
ipad now i just do emails
okay so i got rid of my phone completely
and then was like
i want to go to the countries where i've
been to and toured and only seen a
dressing room
a venue and a bar and then uh so
australia was one of those like i'd
never been to the sydney opera house or
like gone bury a reef properly or even
like gold coast or anything so i rented
a mini
and drove up the coast and then i did
like new zealand and then japan for like
two months
iceland which is great everywhere else
you go to iceland yeah there was a lot
of death wish i feel in your
in your trip iceland was the death wish
i put my um foot in a boiling geezer
upper upper volcano i was walking up
this mud on my 25th birthday
um and i went to iceland to see the
northern lights and i got
uh it went up to the top of a volcano
and we were kind of walking around and
they were like right don't go off the
path
because it's dangerous and i was like
okay didn't really clock it and then i
saw a little like little pool of water
that was kind of bubbling and i was like
that's quite cool volcano bubbling
walked over there like don't walk over
there i was like why and slit the ground
collapse
i don't know if you've ever had an
experience where you felt like you're
gonna die but it literally like went
slow motion i was like
ah right
[Laughter]
i was wearing steel cap timberland boots
so it slipped in
and i kind of fell on the side and and
pulled it out and i i just felt
melting and i was like oh my god god
screaming screaming
and they were like don't take it off
don't take it off and i was like why and
i took my sock off and
all the skin came with it
okay so so even worse that's not the end
of the story
i get i get helicoptered out and they
put a skin graft on it because there's
literally no
no skin and i'm kind of like shaking
like this in bed like trying to get to
bed but i'm kind of like oh man
like in bed and then i just pass out and
then i wake up to the tannoy of the
hotel being like right there it is folks
the greatest sighting of the northern
lights in the last 20 years that won't
be happening again for a while
i was hoping the announcement was there
is folks ed sheeran
it's pretty it's pretty pretty pretty
bad but it's uh yeah i could do it right
now
uh yeah it kind of it just kind of looks
like that um
take your word for it
you're good you're good well you so you
checked out for a year and did yeah
took a whole year off because
i don't know i uh of just turned into a
job interview
because i kind of got to the end of a
five-year tour and
literally had everything to show for it
professionally and nothing to show for
it personally
you you i had all these kind of
accolades and plaques and i was kind of
like wow
everything's good and everyone's like ah
so what what you're up to when you get
back home and i was like no idea like i
don't
i don't know i like and they were like
how was australia i was like well i
could
i could tell you about this bar or like
the plane and i'm
i'm sure you've got that so yeah that's
because i've taken a bunch of trips
where i needed to go
one let memory catch up with me two
check in with just me go to places where
you're anonymous where
you're not you know we live in a world
of miracles there's many places with you
right there
there's a few in in africa i've found
but i mean yeah and i know what you mean
because japan japan was the one for me
like i literally looked at a sales list
of where i'd sold albums in japan was
like
i was like there we go
[Music]
you